thing I like about the percent equation
I think the things that you like about
it too is it's really just like doing a
translation just like if you're
translating from you know one language
into another language we're just
translating this from a sentence into an
equation they call that the percent
equation so let's take it one step at a
time so we have point eight is whenever
you see the word is that means equals so
you can replace is with equals what
percent okay we don't know so I'm just
gonna call this P for the percent okay
of two whenever you see the word of that
means x or multiplication so P times two
so if we divide both sides by two the
twos cancel and you can see P comes out
to 0.4 but P is a percentage so to
convert from a decimal to a percent you
have to move that decimal point one two
places to the right so this becomes
forty percent okay so are you with me so
far
so number two sixty is what percent of a
hundred and sixty okay so we start off
that give us 60 is means equals remember
what percent okay we don't know so again
we're gonna call that P of one hundred
and sixty s that means times 160 so if
we divide both sides by a one hundred
and sixty you can see these are
cancelling and we can divide these both
by 10 so that comes out to six over 16
which reduces to 3 over 8 which comes
out to 0.375 you can do that on your
calculator just take 3/8 that equals P
but again we want to convert from a
decimal to a percentage since P is a
percent move that decimal place two
places to the right so it's going to
come out to 37.5%